for magnus because the e5 pawn  is  falling off and the knight on a7 is  exceptionally bad and the players are  really  speeding up and making the digital board  catch up with him um  because suddenly we have a whole load of  moves okay so we follow wow wow look at  this seven seconds one second what's  going on did he lose on time no no no  they're still going four seconds so i'm  changing sorry things are speeding up so  much what's going on  the players were on one second  it couldn't  so it seems like  magnus  magnus drew i think i don't know maybe  ali firoza just uh it was a draw run out  of time but it's a draw  yes this is the information we receive  well  it was madness at the end no one could  keep up yeah and the players i had to  play thick and fast and you know  it's it's a tough system  well  obviously i mean firoza played  incredible just yeah in the in this game  with so many ideas and  he was so fast